ahora tenemos limpios nuestros motores
les quitamos los cables y están listos
para que les soltemos nuevos cables
elegimos un cable de calibre 18 el cual
es suficiente para lo que hacemos vamos
a determinar cuánto cable vamos a
necesitar lo metemos por acá y el cable
va a tener que llegar a nuestro
controlador del motor hasta aquí que es
donde está nuestro controlador del motor
probablemente pongamos así de este lado
el cable no será demasiado largo pero en
este otro lado sí tendrá que ser más
largo
esta es la longitud que vamos a
necesitar y es un poco más largo que los
cables que teníamos originalmente pero
estos cables son más pequeños y más
fáciles de manipular para cuando hagamos
nuestro cableado además son de cobre y
podrán conducir muy bien la corriente
pelamos el extremo del cable y lo
doblamos así como gancho
y ahora lo podemos colocar aquí en el
contacto del motor tenemos nuestros dos
cables colocados y los apretamos ahora
usamos soldadura con núcleo de resina 60
40 me gusta el núcleo de resina porque
se fija mejor
muy bien
vamos a asegurarnos de que la resina
cubra todo el cobre una buena forma de
hacer esto es calentar el cobre y dejar
que la soldadura fluya sobre este
así y pueden ver que hay una conexión
completa con nuestro motor
ahora ponemos el motor en su lugar y le
pasamos uno de los pinchos alrededor
estos hinchas son mucho más largos de lo
necesario y yo prefiero que así sea ya
que los podemos usar para sujetar
diversas cosas aunque pueden usar unos
más pequeños que son más baratos
vamos a asegurarnos de que está quedando
bien alrededor del motor
este no quiere quedar como queremos
vamos a tratar de reajustar este sitio
estas cosas a veces pasan
vamos a tratar de aflojarlo un poco
quizás deba hacer algo más para que la
cinta tenga un buen contacto con el
motor
aunque quizá funcione bien así
pero quizá debamos lijar estas dos
piezas
este material es duro pero si no podemos
cortar muy bien este será nuestro calce
esperamos que no sea demasiado grande
quizás sí lo sea vamos a tratar de
ponerlo aquí
bien veamos si nuestro motor se mueve
bien y con libertad asienta bien luce
bien y parece que podrá sostener algo de
carga vamos a cortar los sobrantes
y vamos a tratar de ajustar un poco más
los cinchos
ahora hacemos lo mismo del otro lado
y como pueden ver ya terminamos de
colocarlo y recortamos los sobrantes
excelente
ya tenemos nuestros motores en su lugar